The food chain comprises of the producers, consumers and decomposers.
Plants are producers.
They absorb sunlight which is readily available, water and other nutrients from the soil...
...and produce their food through a process called photosynthesis.
Plants are the only living being which creates new energy for the other living beings.
Consumers: animals are consumers.
This is because they don't produce energy, they just use it up.
Animals that eat plants are called primary consumers or herbivores.
Animals that eat other animals are called secondary consumers or carnivores.
If a carnivore eats another carnivore, it is called a tertiary consumer.
Some animals play both roles, eating both plants and animals.
They are called omnivores.
Decomposers: bacteria and fungi are decomposers.
They are also called detritivores.
They eat decaying matter, that is dead plants and animals...
...and in the process, they break them down and decompose them.
When that happens, they release nutrients and mineral salts back into the soil,...
...which then is used by the plants.